ma voi l'avete mai vista una partita di
calcio 100 contro 1
no è mai un software femme du carico e
mangerò davvero anche lingotto japanese
red than the world player of
[Applauso]
the king's knot
ora in questo esperimento folle
giapponese i 100 erano bambini e tre
erano adulti ma nel mondo della
sicurezza informatica della cyber
security e gli attaccanti sono cento
contro solo un difensore è una storia
molto più impari un confronto
assolutamente non nolan ha pari
la storia della cyber security della
sicurezza informatica è una storia
relativamente breve se parla degli
ultimi 20 30 anni al massimo la sua era
d'oro di fatto va ancora disegnata e
probabilmente è proprio in questo
decennio ma il concetto di sicurezza
delle informazioni sicurezza del dato è
un concetto che di fatto è antico come
la storia dell'umanità
siamo evoluti da da una fase in cui si
origlia vano le conversazioni si
necessitava di essere fisicamente
prossimi alla persona che andavamo ad
origliare a una fase dopo in cui è stata
inventata la scrittura e quindi si
potevano intercettare dei messaggi fino
all'attuale capitalismo della
sorveglianza dove teoricamente possiamo
ascoltare qualsiasi conversazione dalla
nostra stanza e quello che ha cambiato
diciamo nel nel corso della storia e il
raggio della nostra capacità di
intercettare
il problema con la sicurezza informatica
con la cyber security è che non
riusciamo a visualizzarla il meglio che
il fior fiore del giornalismo dentale
che hollywood sono riusciti a proporre è
questa immagine stereotipata di un
ragazzino brufoloso nerd con felpa col
cappuccio che dalla sua stanza
smanettando sul computer riaccentrare in
tutti i sistemi al mondo
quindi se riusciamo a trovare quel
singolo ragazzino abbiamo risolto tutti
i problemi a livello di sicurezza
informatica al mondo
se vi interessa invece capire un po più
nel dettaglio cosa vuol dire seriamente
cyber security
provate a fare questo questo sforzo di
immaginazione
siete in iran e il 2008 e siete a capo
del programma di arricchimento nucleare
del paese
chiedete nella vostra stanza avete tutti
i vostri parametri sotto controllo
eppure ogni mese periodicamente il
programma fallisce nessuno riesce a
spiegarsi perché fallisce e c'è una
ragione in realtà perché quello che è
successo veramente nel 2008 a natanz
nella centrale nucleare iraniana è che
qualcuno si è infiltrato nella centrale
e ha infettato probabilmente con una
chiavetta usb i sistemi della centrale
in maniera tale da riuscire a fare una
singola cosa
rallentare ogni 27 giorni il ritmo di
rotazione delle palette
dell'arricchimento appunto dell'uranio
per solo 15 minuti e voi direte ma non
se ne sono accorti gli ingegneri no non
se ne sono accorti perché era
impossibile che se ne accorgessero
perché l'altra cosa che faceva questo
malware che è passato alla storia come
stuxnet era di mandare in loop un video
che appunto faceva vedere che tutto era
sotto controllo quindi voi capite che ci
sono diverse problematiche al riguardo
quello che è cambiato appunto nel corso
della storia che
ci sono stati anche degli altri paesi
appunto ad esempio la russia spostandoci
un po più a nord ha utilizzato spesso
nel corso della storia
l'ucraina come una sorta di test field
di campo di prova delle proprie cyber
army nel 2016 durante la guerra di
crimea per diversi giorni e sotto natale
centinaia di migliaia di persone in
ucraina sono rimaste totalmente al buio
nel blackout più totale non funzionavano
i frigoriferi di casa non funzionavano
le scuole e quello che ha salvato in
qualche modo l'ucraina in quella fase
era che il suo livello di automazione
come sistema paese non era ancora così
avanzato perché la novità è che nel xxi
secolo essere tecnologicamente
arretrati può essere un vantaggio la
disconnessione è un vantaggio rispetto
appunto per una volta diciamo che sono
le economie più avanzate
tecnologicamente che sono più a rischio
facciamo un passo indietro
guerra fredda
siamo appunto
il mondo è governato da un acronimo la
cremo è matt miuccio la schuur
destruction distruzione mutual è
garantita cosa vuol dire era il motivo
per cui nessuno né a mosca né a
washington aveva il coraggio di
schiacciare il famoso pulsante rosso
delle testate nucleari perché chiunque
sapeva che sarebbe partito in direzione
ostinata e contraria un un attacco
dall'altra parte che in un'escalation
che molti temevano all'epoca avrebbe
forse portato anche all'estinzione della
specie umana dalla faccia della terra
cosa è cambiato oggi che oggi non è più
queste tecnologie estremamente
distruttive non sono più ad esclusivo
appannaggio delle grandi superpotenze
mondiali ma di tutta una serie di player
di attori che sono entrati sul mercato
anche alcuni molto piccoli non so se
conoscete questo film è un film del 2014
che si intitola the interview in cui
james franco
caricaturizzati jong un che è il
presidente nordcoreano
come immaginerete a pyongyang non
l'hanno presa benissimo tant'è che nel
giro di qualche giorno il 70 per cento
dei computer aziendali di sony era la
casa di distribuzione del film americano
è stato reso inutilizzabile per
settimane i dipendenti della sony sono
stati costretti a utilizzare nuovamente
carta e penna invece che mandare delle
mail e questo con un attacco partito
dalla piccola nord corea immaginate cosa
può succedere ovviamente sullo scenario
mondiale
storicamente però lo spionaggio è sempre
stata una questione si di expertise ma
anche di soldi si possono rubare i
disegni di una portaerei americana ma
serve comunque puoi avere le finanze per
poterla costruire
ecco questo costo di fatto è totalmente
azzerato nel mondo digitale come abbiamo
visto con l'attacco degli shadow
blockers che sono un po l'equivalente
diciamo di banksy applicato al mondo
della cyber security ovvero sono una
realtà punto anonima che è riuscito ad
entrare nella national security agency
americana la agenzia di sicurezza
nazionale e di fatto a rubare tutte le
armi belliche cyber più avanzate sulla
faccia della terra le più sofisticate e
appunto poi metterle sul mercato
già il mercato il mercato è estremamente
deregolamentato considerate che anche in
guerra ci sono delle regole secondo la
convenzione di ginevra non si possono
bombardare ad esempio degli ospedali
civili anche durante una guerra non si
possono bombardare ma gli si può
togliere l'energia elettrica si possono
rubare le cartelle cliniche
tutta questa parte digitale non è
assolutamente normata
ora ci sono poi altri modi di creare
scompiglio nel mondo del
digitale del cyber ad esempio con
l'intelligenza artificiale questo
cartello di stop che noi vediamo con
delle piccole pecette quasi
impercettibile all'occhio umano
l'intelligenza artificiale che guida le
auto guida autonoma non lo interpreta
come un segnale di stop ma come un
cartello di velocità massima 45 km orari
ora voi capite cosa questo in un mondo
ormai prossimo dove la maggior parte o
comunque buona parte delle macchine
andrà guida autonoma cosa può creare a
livello di scompiglio a livello di
potenziali incidenti a catena il
problema con l'intelligenza artificiale
è che le modifiche per fregarla sono
inintellegibili agli umani prendiamo
quest'altro esempio questa simpatica
foto di un gattino le reti neurali che
stanno dietro agli algoritmi delle
intelligenze artificiali
effettivamente come vedete tutti sono
d'accordo inner nel etichettarlo come
gattino
ma cosa succede se diamo ad applicare
una piccola perturbazione avversaria
creata appunto da un cyber attacco che
questa questa rete che abbiamo aggiunto
è che appunto totalmente invisibile
all'occhio umano
in realtà fa sì che le reti neurali in
quel caso lì non lo riconoscano più come
un gattino ma come uno struzzo ora voi
capite questo cosa può portare
ovviamente su scala mondiale
dicevamo del mercato deregolamentato uno
degli esempi a quello delle zero days
giorni zero sono vulnerabilità non
conosciute che vengono scoperte da degli
hacker per la prima volta e vengono
spesso rivendute alle stesse case madri
a cui sono state scoperte
ad esempio sciocchi bekrar che è un
hacker molto famoso ha creato qualche
anno fa un'azienda che si chiama 0 lium
e che ha pubblicato in maniera direi
piuttosto sfacciata online un listino
prezzi organizzato tra l'altro in
maniera molto gradevole come una tavola
periodica degli elementi dove per ogni
singolo a vulnerabilità viene pagato
come premio alla ker che l'ha trovata ad
esempio per whatsapp un milione di
dollari per una vulnerabilità
sconosciuta su iphone fino a 2 milioni
di dollari quindi capite che è un
settore piuttosto redditizio che sia
redditizio ce ne siamo accorti anche
dagli attacchi ram souwer che sono degli
attacchi in cui si entra dentro un
sistema si crittografa know tutti i dati
e poi si chiede un riscatto un ransom
appunto per ridare indietro la chiave
per riavere i propri dati indietro in
media un attacco di questo genere e
frutta a chi roberts per da circa 3
milioni di dollari e i target possono
essere università comuni regioni aziende
private condotte del gas
in america recentemente e non sempre è
facile capire chi sono i buoni e chi
sono i cattivi perché ad esempio le
aziende che fanno questi attacchi di
ransomware in alcuni casi hanno dei
principi etici per cui ad esempio non
attaccano gli ospedali o non attaccano
organizzazioni non governative ed hanno
in alcuni casi addirittura parte dei
loro guadagni in beneficenza quindi
altre tipologie diciamo di potenziali
attacchi se ad esempio a quello del
phishing il phishing è un'attività anche
qua malevola e fraudolenta che ad
esempio di manda dei messaggi dove ci si
finge ad esempio i vostri sistemi
bancari e vi si chiedono le vostre
credenziali per entrare e ovviamente
poter rubare le vostre finanze altre
cose e considerate che questa tipologia
di attacchi non riguardano solo gli
analfabeti funzionali vogliano alfabeti
digitali una carta di credito su due
negli stati uniti è stata clonata e non
solo quella della zia maria anche quella
di barack obama
ora noi siamo consapevoli di essere
davanti solo alla punta della punta
dell'iceberg
anche perché la prima regola nel mondo
degli hacker è mai parlare di hacking ma
c'è un problema strutturale direi
all'interno dei grandi centri di
innovazione ad esempio in silicon valley
c'è uno dei botti di mark zuckerbeg
prima del recente turn around verso il
mondo del metaverso è nu fest e break
sings muoviti veloce e rompi le cose il
contrario di quello che un buon
consulente di cyber security di
consiglierebbe il contrario
probabilmente di quello che anche il
buon senso suggerirebbe il risultato
mezzo miliardo di account di facebook
sono stati hackerati ora mi rendo conto
che se è difficile fare previsioni
soprattutto sul futuro come diceva
fisico danese niels bohr ma ho come ad
esempio testimoniano delle frasi come
questa nessuno avrà mai bisogno di più
di 637 kilobyte e di memoria
un computer una frase pronunciata
esattamente 40 anni fa da un signore che
peraltro poi prima di fare soldi con i
vaccini qualche computer l'avrebbe poi
venduto il signor bill gates ma
nonostante questo mi sento comunque di
fare una scommessa perché una scommessa
veramente molto facile
gli attacchi aumenteranno e aumenteranno
in maniera esponenziale
banalmente perché siamo nell'era
dell'aiot il internet of things
l'internet delle cose che nel mondo
cyber security è conosciuta che come
internet o lo stress delle minacce
ora dopo questo piccolo excursus avrete
capito che non c'è poi così tanto da
preoccuparsi c'è proprio da
terrorizzarsi per cui veniamo forse la
parte che vi interessa di più in questa
fase è il messaggio più di speranza come
ci proteggiamo qua dobbiamo distinguere
tra tre categorie le aziende i sistemi
paese e i singoli individui per le
aziende un buon modo a partire da quella
che è nota come assunzione di
compromissione bild it like it's broken
costruisci lo come se fosse già bucato
siccome è molto probabile appunto che
qualcuno entri nei vostri sistemi una
maniera saggia di costruirli è di creare
dei compartimenti stagni oltre cui non
si riesce non si riesca ad andare in
eventuali attacchi
se dovete entrare in un sottomarino e
sapete che prima o poi questo
sottomarino
diciamo farà entrare dell'acqua è bene
isolare quella parte e mettere in
sicurezza ovviamente l'equipaggio per i
sistemi paese è più una questione
diciamo di investimenti e di volontà
politica
parlavamo prima della convenzione di
ginevra la convenzione di ginevra è
stata siglata nel 1864 a più di 150 anni
aggiornarla oggi in un'era in cui siamo
connessi per cinque sei ore al giorno
non è solo un nostro diritto è un nostro
preciso dovere nei confronti delle
prossime generazioni
così come è un nostro dovere un gesto di
civiltà necessario non lasciare il
famoso difensore da solo contro i 100
attaccanti
e veniamo infine abbiamo personale
ricordatevi intanto questo consiglio
molto spicciolo che si rifà un acronimo
autenticazione a due fattori che è
quello che vi permette di verificare che
effettivamente se quello che sta
entrando in questo momento dal vostro
computer di casa dentro la vostra home
banking siete effettivamente voi tramite
un doppio controllo un doppio check su
un altro dispositivo banalmente sul
vostro cellulare
poi mi rendo conto che sia difficile nel
xxi secolo consigliarvi di digitalizzare
vi meno ma almeno cerchiamo di
digitalizzarsi meglio o meglio con più
consapevolezza vale per l'utilizzo della
rete in generale anche perchè per la
prima volta nel corso della storia
dell'umanità
non solo i nostri sistemi ma la nostra
stessa mente è diventata hacker abile
come sostiene lo storico israeliano io
vanno a rari e qui non parlo guardate di
onde cerebrali alla ilon mask o di miura
link parlo di una cosa molto più
spicciola la nostra libertà di pensiero
quindi qui dimenticatevi il ragazzino
con la felpa col cappuccio e
concentriamoci su quello che invece
potrebbe essere veramente il vero
colpevole ovvero i sistemi degli
algoritmi
secondo uno studio dell'università di
cambridge del 2015 con 70 like un
algoritmo vi conosce meglio di un vostro
amico 6 reich salgono a 300
l'algoritmo di conosce meglio del vostro
partner dei vostra moglie del vostro
marito per cui la domanda che dovete
farvi e quanti like sono necessari
all'algoritmo per conoscerci meglio di
noi stessi
se state cliccando sull'immagine di un
uomo a torso nudo in una pubblicità
piuttosto che una donna state dando
informazioni all'algoritmo che forse
neanche voi sapete di sapere o in
qualche modo accettate di sapere e
questo vale per le nostre preferenze
sessuali ma anche per altre inclinazioni
che sono coperte in ogni caso da dada
byas dai nostri pregiudizi per cui e qui
chiudo oltre alle informazioni che
rischiano di essere rubate che sono il
mestiere effettivamente che faccio della
cybersecurity
state molto attenti alle informazioni
che deliberatamente scegliete di
condividere e di regalare agli algoritmi
perché non era in cui non solo i nostri
possedimenti ma la nostra stessa
identità non è mai stata così digitale
difendere i nostri dati online significa
in ultima istanza difendere chi siamo
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]